hey
[Music]
you haven't spent it on drugs no not at
all
not at all
right now if i do drugs i would be it
would be a
disaster it would be disaster
yeah
i'm like a ticking time bomb
hi david yeah good to see you again you
called me early this morning yeah
and told me you were
gonna commit suicide all right
tell me what's what's going on what's
going on in your head well uh i'm i'm i
take medication and and uh it's a shot
that i take you know when i don't have
that shot i hear voices and
uh
i start getting real depressed
you know
i just don't want to live because
because of all the baggage and all the
trauma i've been through
and uh this is like the ninth time i've
done this
this in six months and this has been a
real bad stressful year
because uh it's
uh when i when i was 19 i lost my
daughter and uh she got hit by a car she
was four years old and uh
you didn't tell me this yeah
yeah i have this is the tattoo right
here um and uh i just i think about [ __ ]
like that you know
it is
i really need my medication you know you
know
it's so you get your medication how
often david uh once a month once a month
and are you due for your next yeah i'm
over i'm late they're lazy so why are
you not taking it um because
the
program i'm in
they they're late on it they're they're
they're slow and uh they missed the shot
they weren't paying attention
and um and you end up in a situation
like this yes or your mental state is
not yeah and i had one i warned them
this week that it's about to happen they
didn't listen to me
and you know
i guess that's what's wrong with the
system they don't
they don't
they don't take it serious
you know well somebody needs to take
your situation seriously yeah
yeah because look at the situation
you're in you're you're calling me and
you're you tell me you're gonna commit
suicide yeah and i meant to i was really
gonna end it because i i just i can't
take this [ __ ] no more
the voices are just and you're walking
around the streets of south central no
i stayed at the bus stop for like two
hours and then uh
i i was gonna pick a fight at the house
because
the they were making fun of crazy people
last night people with mental health
problems and i i was gonna
pick a fight with the dude that started
it but i don't wanna go back to jail
and uh
i i don't want to hurt nobody but that's
how i was feeling you know
yeah the mental state you're in right
now
is not something that common sense and
reason are going to get you out of
right your meds are probably going to be
there
so getting in a fight committing suicide
anything you're considering right now is
probably not the answer
like right now i'm hallucinating i'm
seeing like [ __ ] because i took 20
suboxones last night you took what 20
suboxone 20. yeah and uh one suboxone
can overdose you
and uh
i i just i didn't i just kept taking
them just so [ __ ] would just stop you
know
playing a voice would stop but it didn't
and what do the voices say to you uh
they tell me that people are after me
that uh
that uh
that i'm not worth living and then they
tell me run run run cut yourself
roger's after you
and uh
or go hit somebody who's roger the guy
that written
no i thought the story you told me was
that you were
molested raped by uh
family members yeah he was he was an
adopted brother oh he was an adopted
brother yeah oh i see
yeah
is he still around
uh i was looking for him
uh
but i stopped looking he's just
somewhere in florida
and uh
he ran when he found out i was looking
for him he
he he left his house he took off that's
what my sister told me
and i really scared him did he do this
to other people or just you yeah five
different people five different people
but he i never got my
my my day in court with him
i i got screwed out of that you know
you know do you feel like what happened
to you as a young man is unresolved yeah
you've never really talked about it
but you had a therapist right
uh yeah in prison but uh i
they it's like a high and by type of
thing they
it's really like 20 minutes and that's
it oh really and what about therapy
since you've been out
uh i i can't afford it
uh but if i get get the money i'll i'll
definitely i know a psych that will take
me in you know a good therapist yes yes
you just can't afford it i can't afford
it yeah i mean how often would you want
to go i'll go every day
i'll go every day
you know like
uh seven days if i had to because i i
how much is a therapist for you
um like 1200 a week twelve hundred a
week yeah yeah
yeah well there's a there's a gofundme
campaign on connected with my channel
that uh i can't think of anyone other
than alicia and patience oh okay there
would be more
okay worthy of our help we'll see if we
can't uh
get you some help yeah yeah i i would
really appreciate because i hate seeing
you like this yeah i mean this is awful
yeah because now i'm gonna have to end
up going to a psych hospital and get
admitted and so what will happen now
they're going to move me into a hospital
a 51 50 hole 51.50 hold yeah it says for
people with uh that try to commit
suicide they don't want they say you're
a danger to yourself will they get your
meds yeah well that's the most important
thing yeah yeah
yeah and then i it will give me time to
detox off the suboxone
you know
tell me about the drug use you've been
using or not using i haven't been using
and is that a good thing or a bad thing
it's a good thing because oh it's a bad
thing because um because you were
telling me in the car i depend on drugs
it calms me down you know yeah i've
heard this from a lot of addicts right
who will tell me that drugs like crystal
meth or crack will actually calm them
down
calming down whereas with everyone else
it's the opposite yeah yeah
i got adhd and that's a it's uh i'm
hyper i'm more hyperactive like i can't
i get maybe an hour of sleep a night
really yeah
it's torturing me like like
i don't know what to do you know i know
what to do but i
don't know what to do at the same time i
just
it's frustrating
and crystal meth will calm me down yeah
yeah
the only thing i do when i'm on
christmas i walk forever i walk from
here to hollywood and back all day long
and i get to think and and it makes me
concentrate
it gives me a peace of mind it really
does it really does but
i'm not
gonna go to the drugs because i'm on
probation and it's just i want to try
something new you know i want to try it
i know you've been working out a lot you
told me that yeah i mean uh four hours a
day yeah i do 1200 puts per day four
four hours a day working out yeah wow
you know and i i bought a speed bag and
a punchy bag and a couple weights with
the money i've made so
yeah and the money you've made how uh
well
with uh like i sell cigarettes and then
which would you help me with yeah yeah
and then um just i'm a hustler i never
run out of money like
uh but what i use my money i usually
use my money on workout stuff like i
have a lot of workouts though
i'm addicted to working out you know
you can find worse vices than that yeah
yeah
you know
yeah you know
right now i'm
i i'm in a
state of mind where like i want to fight
and it's i i got registered hands so
i could go to jail you know what i so
i need to get yeah you were telling me
in the car you're a golden glove yeah
boxer for 17 years uh
broadway in manchester broadway gym
yeah
tell me about that um i've been going
there since uh
since i was
14 and and they brought me up like a son
like my trainer was like a dad to me
and i took it i was the one that was
always coming early and leaving late
because i
i took my training rules you're a boxer
yes yes yes wow yes
um i fought fernando vargas you ever
heard of fernando vargas no i haven't
he's out of oxnard he he's he's a he's a
real he he's a professional boxer i'm
not professional but i sparred with him
yeah at the kelowna colonia boxing gym
it's in oxnard what's your record um i
got okay i'm not sure i out of 100
fights i've won maybe 70.
i've lost a lot because they all i'm
my my weight
i'm always fighting bigger guys like
because um
i'm all i'm i'm
i'm uh not as tall as usually far as
they got a longer reach you know oh i
see yeah
but uh yeah i love it i love boxing it
really helps yeah it probably helps you
release yeah so your
anger i would think yeah when i was in
prison i i never lost the fight like
it was
like
you know i'm not bragging blaze
it is you know
but
yeah
i i'm really aggravated and just
frustrated right now because the system
is [ __ ] up
i i've been telling them all week that i
need my medication and i knew you're at
the mercy of who to get your medication
um
uh
it's my mental health please
they used to be good but after the kobe
they just
for some reason no you should have
access to your meds when you need them
yeah yeah
well they stopped giving me my
bottles because i was i was overdosing
oh you're abusing them yeah so i get
everything by injection now
so how many times have you done things
like what you did this morning
uh in six months i've done this nine
times
it's been a bad year i've been really
depressed this year
yeah the last five times i've seen you
you've been great
right you seem like you're on the road
to recovery right
right
and this
yeah this i knew it was coming because
uh i felt it you your body will tell you
whence when you're about to lose like
yeah that was a creepy text i got for
you this morning yeah yeah what did it
say
i didn't know how to yeah it says i'm
sorry for that but i was crying for help
mark i need to talk to you i think i'm
gonna commit suicide yeah
goodbye yeah
goodbye oh good oh yeah that's what i
got from 6 20 this morning when i came
out of the gym and i don't know where
you were yeah i
i wasn't going to call nobody but that
would have been a mistake i'll probably
wouldn't be here right now
and um
no i'm happy to talk to you anytime yeah
yeah
i just gotta learn that my life is worth
living you know because i just
i'm 41 and i just don't
uh i think therapy was what would help
you the most just to break down
what happened to you as a young man
right right you know because no one
should live with that right no one
should have to but
we can't erase that but
if we can talk about it we can break it
down
yeah
yeah therapist to help you
work it out talk about it sort it out
and see that you're not at fault you're
not to blame right right yeah it was
um
was it the pain of that that does the
cause yeah i have a lot of regrets like
yeah i'm sure yeah it's
what happened was
um it was going on in my house so
long that i thought it was right i
thought it was i thought it was all
right normal you know like that was
normal
i i started changing that doubt like
maybe
two weeks after it happened i i had a
real bad feeling like i did something
wrong and i was like
so i live but you were a young man yeah
i was 13 14 years old it was my eighth
grade
uh into my freshman year yeah
no
oh david yeah i feel for you
we'll get you a new shirt yeah
so you don't look like you murdered
somebody oh you weren't horrifying yeah
and i just i just bought that jacket too
and i got blood all over it so but yeah
i can give you some clothes here
yeah
all right david well let's see if we can
maybe get some donations and get you
some therapy okay that might help
yes yes
maybe your meds too that would be great
yeah i really i really
uh i'm really uh so i'm confused on how
this is gonna play out like
like uh
i don't know what's gonna happen you
know it's it's it's i know this much i'm
not gonna do no drugs and i'm gonna stay
on the right track as much as i can you
know well when you do this does it
relieve some of the pressure yes so
you're kind of mellow for a while
until it builds again right right
because for the last few weeks you've
been telling me how great everything is
how good you feel yeah you seem much
better so that's great i thought you're
on the right track and then this happens
yeah
yeah
i i lied i
i just wanted to let you know like you
know
about 50 of the time i was like
lying because but i just wanted you to
think that i was on the right check you
know i said i had i hadn't done no drugs
but
i have
you you're not as you're not as good as
you make up right an impression on right
right
yeah that's right
no david you don't deserve anything
you're going through you don't deserve
any of this we just need you to get we
need to get you some help
okay
yeah all right david thank you very much
you